I know I should have had butterflies
about Harry
Hamilton that's what's
normal but I never
did I had those
feelings I have those
feelings about
girls and I tried to be like
you but I'm just
not Mar walked in in
me in New York with with a
maid she looked at me like I was a
monster a I'm so
sorry what did she
say she
just walked back out like I was
nothing May will listen to
me
listen you're talking
about
[Music]
love how can love ever be
wrong if that's what gives you
butterflies then you are exactly who
you're supposed to
be you're Mabel you're
beautiful you're not disgusted
Charlie
shame you have to and let that
[Music]
go you're too lovely to be
Ro thank you for telling
[Music]
me